I want you to touch your face go on what
do you feel soft squishy Q right you're
doing you well it's not quite true
you're actually healing thousands of
microscopic creatures that live on our
face and fingers you're feeling some of
the fungi that drifted down from the air
ducts
today they set off our allergies and
smell of mildew you're feeling some of
the 100 billion bacterial cells that
live on our skin
they've been munching away at your skin
oils and replicating producing the
smells of body odor you're likely even
touching the fecal bacteria that's
sprayed on to you the last time you
flushed a toilet or those bacteria that
live in our water pipes and spray it on
to you with your last shower sorry
you're probably even giving a
microscopic high-five the two species of
mites that live on our faces on all of
our faces they've spent the night
squirming across your face and having
sex on the bridge of your nose
many of them are now leaking their gut
contents onto your pores now look at
your finger
how's it feel gross in desperate need of
soap or bleach that's how you feel now
but it's not going to be how you feel in
the future
for the last 100 years we've had an
adversarial relationship with the
microscopic life nearest us if I told
you there was a bug in your house or
bacteria in your sink there's a human
devised solution for that a product to
eradicate exterminate disinfect we
strive to remove most of the microscopic
life in our world now but in doing so
we're ignoring the best source of new
technology on this planet the last 100
years have featured human solutions to
microbial problems with the next 100
years will feature microbial solutions
to human problems I'm a scientist and I
work with researchers at North Carolina
State University the University of
Colorado to uncover the microscopic life
that is nearest us and that's often in
our most intimate and boring
environments be it under our couches in
our backyards or in our belly buttons
and I do this work because it turns out
that we know very little about the
microscopic life that's nearest us as of
a few years ago no scientist could tell
you what bugs or microorganisms within
your home your home the place you know
better than anywhere else and so I and
teams of others are armed with q-tips
and tweezers and advanced DNA techniques
to uncover the microscopic life nearest
us in doing so we found over 600 species
of bugs that live in USA homes
everything from spiders and cockroaches
to tiny mites that cling to feathers and
we found over 100 thousand species of
bacteria and fungi that live in our dust
bunnies thousands more that live on our
clothes or in our showers
we've gone further still and we looked
at the microorganisms that live inside
the bodies of each of those bugs in our
home in each bug for example a wasp we
see a microscopic jungle unfold in a
petri plate a world of hundreds of
vibrant species
behold the biological cosmos so many of
the species you're looking at right now
don't yet have names most of the life
around us remains unknown I remember the
first time I discovered and got to name
a new species with a fungus that lives
in the nest of a paper wasp it's white
and fluffy and I named it nuke or NIDA
kolja meaning in Latin that it lives in
the nest of another this is a picture of
it growing on a dinosaur because
everyone thinks dinosaurs are cool at
the time I was in graduate school and I
was so excited that I found this new
life-form I called up my dad and I go
dad I just discovered a new michael
rowdyism species he laughs and he goes
that's great I hope you also discovered
a cure for it sure ed now my dad is my
biggest fan so in that crushing moment
where he wanted to kill my new little
life-form I realized that actually I
failed him both of the daughter and a
scientist my years toiling away in labs
and in people's backyards investigating
and cataloging the microscopic life
around us I never made clear my true
mission to him my goal is not to find
technology to kill the new microscopic
life around us my goal is to find new
technology from this life that will help
save us the diversity of life in our
homes is more than a list of 100,000 new
species there's 100,000 new sources of
solutions to human problems I know it's
hard to believe that anything that's so
small or only has one cell can do
anything powerful but they can these
creatures are microscopic alchemists
with the ability to transform their
environment the
an arsenal of chemical tools this means
that they can live anywhere on this
planet and they can eat whatever foods
around them this means they can eat
everything from toxic wastes to plastic
and they can produce waste products like
oil and battery power and even tiny
nuggets of real gold they can transform
the inedible engine nutritive they can
make sugar into alcohol
they give chocolate its flavor and soils
the power to grow I'm here to tell you
the next 100 years will feature these
microscopic creatures solving more of
our problems we have a lot of problems
to choose from we've got the mundane as
smelling clothes or bland food and we've
got the monumental disease pollution war
and so this is my mission to not just
catalog the microscopic life around us
but to find out what it's uniquely
well-suited to help us with here's an
example we started with a pest a wasp
that lives on many of our homes inside
that wasp we plucked out a little-known
microorganism species with a unique
ability it can make beer this is a trait
that only a few species on this planet
have in fact all commercially produced
beer you've ever had likely came from
one of only three microorganism species
yet our species it can make a beer that
tasted like honey and you can also make
a delightfully tart beer in fact this
microorganism species that lives in a
belly of a wasp it could make a valuable
sour beer better than any other species
on this planet there are now four
species that produce commercial beer
where you used to see a pest
now think of tasting your future
favorite beer as a second example I
worked with researchers to dig in the
dirt in people's backyards there we
uncovered a microorganism that could
make novel antibiotics antibiotics
that can kill the world's worst
superbugs this was the awesome thing to
find but here's the secret for the last
60 years most of the antibiotics on the
market have come from similar soil
bacteria every day you and I and
everyone in this room and on this planet
are saved by similar soil bacteria that
produce most of our antibiotics where
you used to see dirt now think of
medication perhaps my favorite example
comes from colleagues who are studying a
pond scum microorganism which is
tragically named after the cow dung it
was first found in it's pretty
unremarkable and would be unworthy of
discussion except that the researchers
found that if you feed it to mice it
vaccinates against PTSD it backs some
eats against fear where you used to see
pond scum now think of hope there are so
many more microbial examples that I
don't have time to talk about today I
give you examples of solutions that came
from just three species but imagine what
those other 100,000 species and your
dust bunnies might be able to do in the
future you might be able to make use
next year or smarter or perhaps live
longer so I want you to look at your
finger again think about all those
microscopic creatures that are unknown
think about in the future what they
might be able to do or make or whose
life they might be able to save how does
your finger feel right now a little bit
powerful that's because you're feeling
the future
thank you
[Applause]